snapped in Melbourne Australia
Noba the Lyrebird is a master minute
wire birds are like the Impressionists
of the bird world okay
camera shutter it's like this ah that's
pretty good
cuckoo Burroughs I guess you guys ready
for a pigeon yeah we're actually good
let's leave it to the pros Shelley what
makes Nova such an epically skilled
imitator birds make sounds in a
different way than we do we have a voice
box that sits on top of our windpipe
lungs to force the air out and lips to
shake the air on its way out
birds have a different organ called the
series that sits just above the lungs
and this splits into two enabling them
to make two different sounds at exactly
the same time on the same breath so you
is know much as parroting the sounds
around him fire birds are amazing they
have exceptional hearing and memory that
allows them to mimic almost anything
they hear in fact up to 80% of a
lyrebirds repertoire can be just mimicry
it takes a lot of time and effort to
perfect these songs and juvenile liar
birds will spend a lot of time learning
to mimic the sounds of the adults around
them and it could be the sounds of other
males species of birds but also could be
the sounds that humans make like those
camera shutters are those car alarms so
they may be young wire birds that have
learnt the sound of a car alarm from an
older like a bird but they've never
actually heard one and may never hear